france says its special forces have
killed the leader of isil in the greater
sahara region
adnan abu walid al-sahrawi was behind
the killing of six friend charity
workers and their nigerian driver last
year president emmanuel macron held the
operation as a success in france's fight
against armed groups in west africa's
sahel
nicholas hack has more from dhaka
we've heard from the french defense
ministry that this
neutralizing of uh of el saurari as as
they as emmanuel macron describes it
happened in august but it's only now
that they're announcing the official
death of the head of ice the isil
affiliate in the region this el sawari
was behind numerous attacks against
american forces in niger but also
against french forces and african malian
forces on the ground in the tri border
area of burkina faso mali
he is a significant figure he was part
of an other armed group before that
al-marabi tune who was responsible for
the attack on a hotel in bamako but
before that he was part of mujao which
was a group that took over the north of
mali so this is a significant attack at
least
from from the french's perspective the
timing of it is interesting because just
yesterday we heard of mali the the new
malian authority led by by by the
military there
wanting to uh to
engage with russian mercenaries to
reinforce uh their position in mali and
try to fight off armed groups now france
has said that that is unacceptable if
that was the case then they will pull
out altogether we heard from the german
defense minister yesterday saying that
they would do the same we know that the
russian mercenary group wagner is
present in the central african republic
and there's been talks and discussions
happening in in mali but nonetheless
this is a significant uh uh announcement
by the french to try to bolster that
they are the one
there to ensure security